[Music]
now as we've just been discussing uh
people are pretty Fed Up of the
conservative party that much is clear in
the polls and it's also clear um from
extensive polling that not everybody is
very excited about Labor and the thought
of an incoming labor government which
should you'd think uh pave the way for
uh other parties a third party to emerge
I'm going to discuss this now with
Richard TI who is the uh leader of
Reform the Reform Party and Kelly Jade
Keane who is founder of standing for
women uh and is attempting to form a new
or has been attempting to form a new
political party called the party of
women is that right Kelly Jane the party
of women it is yes
that's house um uh Richard I'll start
with you you are now the third party uh
in British politics uh according to the
latest polling you're on 11% above uh
the liberal Democrats on about 10%
though I accept these things are
variable
um that's taken uh it's taken you a
while to get some of the political
momentum you probably expected a bit
sooner uh do you anticipate now surging
ahead into 2024 yeah look building any
brand in any Walk of Life takes time and
a lot of hard work in particular in the
political world where you've got a
basically a two-party system first pass
the post that that solidifies and
reinforces that system but actually
we're making great progress no one else
ever has achieved what reform UK has
achieved in two years going from
essentially somewhere around 1% up to 10
11% I suspect by early 24 will be 12%
plus and that's basically because people
feel politically homeless in the two
main parties they both represent a
different differing forms of socialism
High tax High regulation Mass
immigration pret zero Nanny State
meaning low growth and people are saying
that's not very attractive what else is
out there and word is spreading in the
pubs and clubs and the bus stops and I'm
delighted we're making great great
progress and look Rome is not built in a
day but we're heading north and success
breeds success so I think people should
not underestimat us in the election year
of 2024 you changed your uh name from
the brexit party to Reform Party um you
hinted in a recent article that you
thought perhaps that had been a mistake
do you do you still think that would you
like to clarify
that look fundamentally the country
needs massive reform everywhere that's
why we changed it the brex party is a
very well-known brand so a brand
specialist would say well why did you
change we changed because we trusted the
conservatives uh when they said get
brexit done we thought they actually
meant it and uh but actually given that
there's so many problems across the
whole piece we don't regret it it just
means it takes a bit longer for people
to recognize who you are where you've
come from what we've done on our logo is
we've actually added in the words the
brexit party so we're called reform UK
but the logo also includes the brexit
party that provides a bit of extra
Clarity and linkage for people but no
we're very proud of of our brand and
what we were achieving and Kelly Jane
your party was initially uh rejected I
think I'm right in saying by the
Electoral uh commission um it seemed to
me on a point of procedure yeah uh can
you can you clarify what's going on
there well look I don't want to uh cast
aspersions at the um Commission Office
the Electoral Commission office but they
have been rejecting us since March so
I've now instructed a barrister to make
sure that every single T and and uh I is
is perfectly dotted because I I just
don't want to give them any uh any
reason to dismiss us again uh so no
stone left unturned so that's why we've
we've got a barister and I'm very
confident in the in our electoral
process and our democracy that that
we'll be registered really soon and your
intention for for you yourself is to
stand either against Eddie isard uh in
Sheffield or against K starma himself is
that
right yeah well I think Eddie's now
going for Brighton so it was going to be
kissed armor but I look it it will
depend as we near the election where I
will stand I think you know there's
there's a lot of lovely MPS right across
the board that I would stand against
Stella crey would be one of them I think
there's so many so many in all political
parties uh who've just turned their
backs on women as well as huge sways as
a population you know most people know
that women don't have penises and and
it's about time that parties said it and
the the conservative party are a little
bit too late with their their sort of
strength on this topic and they're still
really not far enough for me you know
there's still this stuff has has got
ravaged through schools you know the I I
visited a school recently it's this
stuff is everywhere so there is a there
is a calling for a party that represents
women and that would be mine and by this
stuff you mean uh the trans
agenda I don't just think it's that but
is that look that is the most egregious
lie and upon which the foundation uh
upon which so many other lies rest so
the gr would be something the gender
recognition act would be something I
would like to see completely repealed um
I want all of this stuff out of schools
as of yesterday not just trans stuff but
other lies that we consistently tell
children um but I I just think this is
the most egregious when you're talking
about the fundamentals upon which all of
us are here you know a woman gives birth
to babies and a man is the the person
that impregnates that woman and I think
it's um it's Bonkers but yeah the the
too many lies but but that's that's the
biggest uh Richard Kelly's attempts uh
to speak up for women there are often
branded as sort of culture Waring and so
on uh do you think the Reform Party is
in a good position on the culture wars
or do you think uh the Tory party which
is sort of dabbling a little bit in
culture wars uh has stolen a bit of your
old Thunder
there uh far from it actually the Tory
party have given up on standing up for
uh British culture British values
they're all over the place on this and
it's only reform actually that have been
really strong amongst the top three or
four polling parties we've made it
absolutely crystal clear there should be
none of this uh gender questioning
allowing any social transitioning any
debate about this in schools up to the
age of 18 we think it's it's absurd I'm
going to campaign events up and down the
country parents and grandparents are
utterly fuming and Furious at what is
going along uh the uh the sort of the
hiding of information the Third party
providers some of whom providing
material that is nothing short frankly
of revolting we've been Crystal Clear we
ban the whole lot and it's the sort of
thing that actually you could do within
just a few days let me tell you what I'd
do Freddy if I was prime minister I'd
instruct the Secretary of State for
education to write to ofstead to write
to every single head teacher of every
primary and secondary school saying this
stops by Friday and anybody who carries
on is fired no ifs no buts it's a breach
of cont contracts here's the most
important thing though it's the clearest
most dangerous breach of safeguarding
I've ever seen and I've been a governor
of four different schools you see all
these safeguarding documents hundreds
and hundreds of pages long this is the
most obvious clear breach and it should
stop and for the prime minister to say
back in March that he was going to carry
out an urgent review my definition of
urgent is by the end of the day or the
end of the week we're in December and
there's no sign of this review they're
all over the place and they're letting
children down it's a disgrace Kelly Jan
I know you've got your own uh political
Ambitions but are you persuaded by
Richard's uh pitch there I am I think
it's it's a barometer of where we are as
a society that that the smaller of the
major three parties is having to say
this because the two main parties have
failed dismally to say it but yes look
anybody speaking about the truth about
this about uh whether or not human
beings can actually change sex I wel all
of that discourse I think it's really
really needed one thing that we want to
do as a party of women is we want to
build from the bottom up so whilst I
have Ambitions to become an MP or I I
really have Ambitions to to make a big
noise so that other people can
understand what the issues are and force
people into positions that's that's my
ambition um but I want I want grind up
so I want women in seats uh right across
the country in councils because that's
where really d direct politics happens
whether or not um an elderly woman in
her home when she says she'd like a
female carer to come and intimately care
for her I want that woman to know that a
female will actually turn up not not a a
cheap worker um who's a man or a a man
in a dress I I just I just think those
things are really crucial so I'd like us
just to populate the local councils and
the pcc's and all of those where direct
uh democracy and politics really
happen do you think uh people will call
you a single isue party a single-issue
politician uh do you think you are I
mean are you the the women don't have
penises
candidate well I am that um but I'm I
think look women don't live single issue
lives um and I think it's really
important for both men and women to be
able to walk about their lives and
expect their public services and
institutions to recognize them as men
and women and that Foster caring um and
adoption uh services and all of those
other services are not coopted by what I
think is a quasi religious pernicious
Cult of transgenderism and just and and
lies and and like I said there's other
lies that stem from that so whilst it
may be single issue I mean the brexit
party may have been accused of being
single-issue and I believe we are now no
longer in Europe so I think the power of
single is issue is is perhaps something
that we need in in this country at the
moment so that people can really kind of
stake stake their claim to a particular
principle and that's something that I
think we stand for at the party of women
or we will stand for once we're
registered is a principal Le um party
which is not it's not like come and just
put all of your eggs in our basket but
it's if you care about this particular
issue this is what we're talking
about and
uh Richard I suppose uh the question I
wanted to ask actually both of you is on
this particular issue of uh transgender
the transgender agenda um against
women's rights um the Tory party have
sort of dabbled with it as you say
perhaps ineffectively Richard um but do
we as in the media do we underestimate
quite how the strength of feeling um
that this is generated actually POS you
answer this first the strength of
feeling that this is generated uh among
women that this issue is is now
generating and the the extent to which
women feel um that their rights are now
being infringed by a hostile agenda
yeah yeah well I I see my job as as not
to convince people because everything
everybody I think already agrees with me
it's just about ensuring that women
understand and Men I don't want to just
I'm not just I'm I I am speaking mainly
to women but I think it impacts all of
us that actually there is a space for
those views that it's not it's no longer
um you know a silent majority we have to
people have to speak up and just being a
little bit apathetic and thinking it's
happening somewhere else is not good
enough anymore because for a start it is
happening it's happening everywhere I
spoke to two teachers a couple of weeks
ago who bareface lied to parents um just
it was it's one of the most horrific uh
sort of conversations I've ever had to
have where you just understand that
these people are pretty much paid up
members of a cult and they are willing
to take the place of parents and make
decisions about people's children behind
their back um and sort of treat parents
with absolute contempt so I think once
people understand that it's in their
children's schools I wouldn't like to be
uh I wouldn't like to predict how they
vote in the next election but it it
can't be for either the conservatives or
labor if they really care about this
issue and Richard have you have you
noticed is that I mean cuz your main
issue I think as a party is immigration
now certainly you know post brexit uh
you are becoming the party that talks
about what what you and and farage
call uh the population crisis in Britain
um but how much does that go hand inand
with this more cultural War um stuff
that is is bubbling under the surface in
British politics bubbling Under The Sur
look there are multiple challenges
across frankly the whole nation and many
of them interrelate uh but this this
this issue the trans agenda it is it has
arisen so quickly it surpris so many
decent ordinary folk and parents up and
down the country and when I speak to
groups they just can't believe it it it
flies in the face frankly of all basic
common sense and I think too often
actually politicians fly in the face of
basic Common Sense look we're pretty
strong and robust on a number of these
issues we are comfortable talking about
the uncomfortable for many people we
feel that in a sense we've got the
courage to put a head above the parit
and take the flak because so many
parents they get in real trouble if
they're try and raise this as I'm sure
Kelly has seen with with teachers or
headteachers they're worried that in
some way their their child might be
discriminated against as far as I'm
concerned uh it's absolutely simple
there are two Sexes and two genders male
and female you might feel something else
at some point because you've had a bad
day or a good day fine but I'm just not
buying all this 72 gender 100 gender
stuff you know you talk to ordinary folk
up and down the country they look at you
with amazement they think it's nonsense
they think it's absurd and they just
want actually politicians to get on to
make people's lives better and they're
just furious that so much time and and
sort of cowardice is is wasted on trying
to say that
frankly something just basically isn't
biologically true uh and sort of pretend
that it is and pretend that women can
have penises I mean it's it's the most
absurd statement in the
world uh I'm not going to try and do
what a lot of journalists have done with
you Richard which is try and insinuate
there's some sort of rivalry between you
and Nigel farage because you always
reject that idea but um he has just left
the the celebrity jungle um in third
place he's his public profile has
increased he's made a lot of hints about
coming into politics he's made hints
about wanting to lead the conservative
party um perhaps after it implodes at
the next general election um where do
you stand on if Niger FR wants to go
back to the Reform Party is he the
leader do you do you step aside what
what happens look he's had great fun
playing mischief and causing Division
and divide within the conservative party
but I remind everybody he's our honorary
president he set up the Reform Party
when it was called the brexit party he
has come back from the jungle on great
form a little bit lighter L The
Experience his pole ratings gone through
the roof he's utterly furious at what's
transpired with regard to some of the
key issues that affect uh our quality of
life and I I I I've said very clearly to
everybody the more help that we can get
the better the more that Nigel is able
to help get stuck in put his shoulder
behind the wheel and frankly uh help
save Britain from the state that we're
in then the better and I suspect you'll
be hearing a lot more on this matter in
the coming
weeks Richard and Kelly Jane uh wish you
both uh a politically prosperous 2024
because um given the morban state of
British politics anything new is good uh
I think in our opinion at The
[Music]
Spectator